نتابعها تطورات في السودان وينضم الي من
ام درمان مراسله الجزيره هيثم ويت مرحبا
هيثم دعنا في صوره هذه التطورات المدنيه
التي تشهدها السودان وخاصه
مثلث العاصمه السودانيه
نعم الاوضاع في هذا الصباح تبدو هادئه
نوعا ما وان كان هذا الهدوء تتخلله طلعات
لطيران الجو التابع لسلاح الجيش السوداني
وكانت هناك وكان هناك تحليق لطائرات قبل
او لطائره حربيه قبل قليل وايضا سمعنا
المضادات الارضيه ترد على هذه الطلعات
الجويه هذا هو الحل الذي يعني ذابت عليه
طبيعه هذه المواجهات فيما يخص العمليات
الجويه وايضا لكن من ناحيه الاشتباكات
الارضيه تبدو الامور حتى الان اهدا من
الامس كانت هناك مواجهات داميه خاصه في
منطقه بحري ووسط الخرطوم حيث قال الجيش في
حسب بيانه ان هناك اشتباكات وقعت مع
اسماءها بمليشيات المتمرده مع الجيش في
مناطق وسط الخرطوم وشمال بحري تحديدا وقال
ان القوات الجيش تمكنت من صد هذه
الاشتباكات وايضا كبرت الطرف الاخر خسائر
في الارواح وفي الممتلك في المعدات ايضا
استولت على عدد من العربات القتاليه في
المقابل ايضا القوات الدعم السريع قالت في
بيان لها انما اسمتها
الانقلابيين النظام البائد اشتبكت مع
ارتكازات لهم في مناطق بحري وايضا في وسط
الخرطوم وقالت القوات بانها استولت على
معسكر السواقه ببحر واسرت عدد كبير من
الجنود في الجيش هذه البيانات والاتهامات
المتبادله ايضا تترافق مع ما يجري ميدانيا
من حالات اشتباكات مستمره للشهر الثاني
على التوالي وايضا يعني هذه الاشتباكات
التي باتت تشكل المصدر قلق كبير بالنسبه
للشارع السوداني والمواطنين بالنسبه
للانعكاسات الانسانيه الكبيره التي بدات
تلقي بظلالها على الاوضاع الحياتيه سواء
كانت من الناحيه الانسانيه المعيشيه او من
الناحيه الصحيه او حتى من انعكاسات
المترتبه على الوضع الامني اصبح الاول
الانفلات الذي باتت تشهدها العديد من
المناطق بسبب انتشار الجريمه وخروج
المجرمين من السجون